good to see this man let me get out all
your credits jim breuer okay there's a
lot to promote here you are on us you're
on Kevin can wait with fellow met fan
Kevin J Mon Sigma DBS which is America's
most watched Network I believe from what
I hear on the NFL broadcast room you are
playing a vine coming up on this is on
tomorrow night at 8:00 Eastern at the
Irvine improv Friday and Saturday and
Oxnard interestingly enough I'll tell
you about what's going on in Oxnard on
Saturday as well other than your logic
comedy show and you're also part of the
episodes that you can catch on comedy
central.com of this is not happening
which is about the Mets 2017 season
oh good see you Jim Breuer how do we go
how are you man I'm really good so what
is going on with your Metropolitan's
there was I good was there there a mess
there just a box of mess I went in you
know yeah loving them is it's like being
in love with an alcoholic every year
like no we're better now would we feel
amazing and then July they're in rehab
it just this is not their pitching's a
disaster no he's healthy yeah why is
that I don't understand how a team and
they say well it's all the teams how
does it team two years in a row lose 80%
of its starters that baffles my mind the
odds are astronomical would one is it
the Harvey's of wek he needs he needs
what does he do I know exactly what he
needs he needs to be in a meeting
that's what if not only personal but I
watched his uh his apology when he
missed the game because he broke up at
his girlfriend he sat there and no one
reported this and you can hear all the
rumblings they all Bartolo Colon reached
out and Terry's going research agreed
with white people crying cuz he oh
there's something deeper going
no and then he sat there he must have
sniffled hard about 15 times during the
apology you can watch it on YouTube I
like to apologize i I just I just you
know I did the wrong thing
and I just don't wish you jamming yeah
he needs a dish but my first thought was
like so we get in hell you need help we
need to help hmm
if if he's doing this on a press
conference yeah you can only imagine
what he's doing he's 40 pounds lighter
than he was a year ago so you think that
the Mets have it's more than just some
sort of rash of injuries there is a I
don't know I think I was a whole team
okay well T I just I got him I think
it's all in the head uh and then maybe
something worse is what you're saying
yeah who knows Jim Breuer here on the
Rich Eisen show now you are in Oxnard
on July it's my 21st Friday and Saturday
July 22nd yeah on July 22nd this
Saturday in Oxnard California not only
performing at night but during the day
the entire Dallas Cowboys team shows up
for training camp are you kidding me I
could you know I don't even know that
because I'm a I'm a big Cowboys fan now
I grew up the Cowboys how does one grow
up in Long Island New York and root for
the Mets and the Dallas Cowboys I'll
tell you right now the hell does that
it's called 70s TV rich it was do you
remember the your a my I'm 50 I just
turned 50 do you remember that offensive
line
yeah I did stand up they do this they
would they would all stand up in unison
look at the look at the other team and
then go back down that was Powerball it
was grand then you had Staubach doing
the shotgun and and then the eye too
tall Jones and Landry walking with the
hat that was yellow in love with the
Cowboys fell in love with the Cowboys
and I'm I was very excited for the new
team love dak I wasn't confident with
Romo I know he's a great guy and all
that but he mind me of Danny white see
do you remember you know the famous
scene they show
oh the the footage of Montana thrown in
the endzone against the Cowboys just the
famed catch yes but that's not what won
the game if you're a true Cowboy fan you
know we had another minute something
left in the game and the Cowboys got the
ball all they needed was a field goal
and they would have won the game so yeah
the good night or scored Danny white
threw it across field
I believe the Hollywood head Fang 45
yard line
next play bang there in San Fran
territory there's still another 37
seconds left we got four down and then
Danny white fumbled the snap he fumbled
the snap you know it's really crazy when
you think about it Jim Breuer here
because to use this analogy and you
being a Mets fan
everybody thinks the minute the ball
went through Buckner's legs that was the
end of the World Series but that was
game 6 against is a game 7 with a rain
delayed rain rain rain out the next
that's right so it was actually like two
days later is when ever there's so many
different moments in sports where you
think because of how big it was and how
seminal a moment it was that that was
actually a walk-off moment but it was
not no you know and I actually feel bad
for Buckner because if you've been in
that scenario the team was numb how do
you it's the one no one talks about the
wild pitch that set up the whole win I
mean wild pitch with two strikes here
comes the tying run now the winning run
is on sex where were you during that 86
games I we sit in my living room with my
girlfriend and two other friends and the
whole she knew nothing about baseball
and she kept saying you know they still
have a chance
nobody nope but she was right she was
right it was always one of the greatest
that in the 80 hockey team
when Americans beat the Russian this was
the greatest sports event I've ever wins
now that's was
those two that wouldn't be able to
happen today for various reasons one
obviously the whole amateur aspect of it
and two it was played in the middle of
the afternoon and people across the
country didn't know what happened
they actually waited sometimes until
that night to actually watch it that
would never happen today
no no you're actually right you'd see it
in the palm of your hand you know
exactly that's right that's right a
miracle on ice yeah I've already seen
that five times on here yeah yeah yeah
you're telling me we beat the Russians I
just saw that walk on a library i watch
it live Facebook Facebook live I was
watching so now you and Kevin James must
share the the Mets horror stories I
guess on the set of all right it is
definitely a horror story but I do feel
good about next year I'm not gonna lie
to you I think we're gonna make some
good moves you're already back you're
already back no they're not going
anywhere this year right you know in the
other Mets fans like oh girl you it's
not happening yeah it's there's no end
in sight one guy gets good gentleman
goes out they went two in a row and then
next pitchers a disaster they have Jacob
degrom that's all I got he's got good
hair here make it great here is the
image syndergaard of it got great hair
man seen you guys good too but the last
how do you how do you with a lot he's
got really try to rip your wrist Allah
have you ever ripped a lot Rahman
I have not impossible I think I wouldn't
know how to do that you know I love
baseball so much I don't care anyways
says pd's is back and it's warring and
there just did they're doing this
yeah no God all these kids are working
out and the balls are tighter how many
tickets are sown a lot yeah no they're
all-natural on now then come on 30 home
runs in June the Bulls tighter get outta
here I think I've got Jim Breuer I'm
your home runs this year than ever we
think the pitching tomorrow that's true
what is that all there is
well the baseball's are tired of chairs
the kids are bigger it's over because
they work out they eat they he biggie
right right he eats so well you know I
know the last time they said that during
the roid era that's what
the chicks dig the long ball that's
right and boys it's selling tickets
drives me nuts
so why doesn't everybody at home Ronson
you know what everyone why it wasn't why
doesn't conforto have 45 home runs
because they did all right let me ask
you this dee Gordon weighs a buck ten
way he got nailed for a peds never know
though remember Palmeiro he went in
front of Congress said no no chance and
I would have done the same thing I'm
lying
yeah I'm afraid to lose my twenty
billion dollars yeah no I know you
talked about are you on
performance-enhancing drugs I am Legend
for him right now I jack it right in my
right cheeks where I came out is that
Ron my eyes are blazing I could see the
outlining of every can when I go back to
the green room after the show world I'm
like what am I gonna find you're gonna
find me raging degrees going back I
don't know if he's gonna be into that
I'm going to be throwing all the shit's
good well we have we have a bunch of
life savers back bottom in that and you
get some good chips too hey you ever
thought to thumbs up too much I'm scared
absolutely good and then you get the
little granola bar let's go to watching
it you know just again we're in Southern
California ji keep it we gotta keep see
you have to be clever you you seriously
think everything's all natural and make
a face I cannot sit here and say that
with a straight face correct but I
really I don't know I'm in a position of
identity I can't this others me but you
don't think that that's in every single
sport but no and an event that there's
some that there's some you know 21st
century BALCO that's cooking something
up correct look and pee in a cup and you
can't tell of course you know I'm always
worried about that and I went out but
I'm not sitting there wondering that
during watching the game
I'm not sitting there you know I'm not
sitting there wondering that watching
the game like you know it doesn't look
just put it this way I'm not not showing
it to my kids and not sitting around
watching baseball
sure because of that I sure am I in
turned off you know I mean I I'm still
watching I'm still gonna watch you
already talked about that 2018 Mets
season is going to be sunny and
everything oh man things we saw
maintaining it you're thinking about
tomorrow we're you're Annie on Broadway
that's right and we're going to sign
Moustakas sorry Kansas City we're taking
them you're taking Moustakas
David rights never
coming back by the way I'm sure you've
known many diners in Long Island they
serve great Moustakas circa that's right
don't you think oh it was a great loss
Oh God love that moussaka designers in
Long Island you've shopped upscale late
you stand laying ago 1 a.m. a diner I'll
take the Moustakas me to Moustakas so
check out this man Jim brewer at the
improv and Irvine tomorrow night then
Oxnard levity live comedy club and again
working on new hour you might look out
there and see Dallas Calvados see them
seriously where is there you're an
avocado can go right yeah I can [ __ ] you
up your mother picture I would love that
let me do that I really would wanna be
an honor to do that and then see you
just run out on the field during a 7 on
7 drill I'm and I will then I will deny
knowing you I'm going to feel like a 6
year old boy just looking to love it
it's neat up there it's neat up there
you got the stands and then you see the
two two three practice fields it's
really laid-back you Oh God love that
the stars everywhere man you'll hug me
out I will do that you're done email
here that's how we roll I like leaving
people in a better spot when I found
them I feel much and I can't wait - can
we call can we call somebody to clean up
what's going on to the back over there
sure thank you I may do it yeah because
I'm too busy you means coming out of
sharing at Jim Breuer be re you re are
on Twitter thanks for coming in here
yeah thank you Jim over here check them
out thank you Irvine Oxnard also this is
not happening on Comedy Central and then
of course Kevin can wait on CBS
America's Most Wanted no Rachel the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
radio stations across the country and
audience if you like that please
download our app there's lots of fun
things there other than just more of the
videos you just saw you can call us from
the app you can email us from the app
just download it trust me you'll enjoy